if I were to describe night three in one
words I would call
it
nonstop phase one as a
go from the moment that Jenkins pulls
the trigger there's 57 minutes of
continuous action making it from an
action fanatic standpoint it was
Christmas it's Winston Jeron all our
other characters kind of spread out
throughout the hotel trying to pull off
this impossible
Heist grade
grenade and it's just chaos season on
Winston Sky we wanted to make sure that
it felt John Wick specific in the action
scenes we learned really kind of the DNA
of the hotel which is nothing we've ever
explored in the movies before it's fun
in that John Wick version of fun it's
like the crazier you get the better it
is and the way we
go putting honsel in gretto together was
quite tricky because the wig got cast
first I know I wanted the Ringo Star
hairstyle and then this one face came up
these eyes his face fits with that wig
I'm like he's
perfect I've only directed him once I've
only told him one thing nothing and he
took and created his own character and
there's not a misstep in
[Music]
there he's very machine likee almost
like hold and Terminator
life 20 years experience doing this kind
of stuff you're still getting these
insights from these experts these you
know Masters in their field it's been a
blast my favorite fight scene is between
grle and Yen on the rooftop because it's
just so intense and insanely different
action there is a huge aspect of mystery
in our characters it's all about the
look the attitudes the
movement we know how incredible yen is
as a
fighter but Marina the actress who plays
greto gets to show her real talent
now it's this crazy things she can do
with her
[Music]
body it's been really a bless to work
with Kate and the fight coordinators
they're incredible they can see that
uniqueness and build something amazing
from
you to me fighting is all about the
underlying Primal qualities we humans
love to follow
[Applause]
Winston I personally love the
relationship between Chiron and Winston
I was just so excited for us to be able
to step into these pretty iconic roles
and begin to develop our storyline our
chemistry 13th floor that's bad luck
right I'm not superstitious
I was like okay I'm Winston and you're
Chiron this is exciting after all
they've been through in the sacrifice
they both made there's a moment they
have in the control room where they hug
each other they formed a bond through a
traumatic re episodes and a very violent
history and that's the beginning of that
relationship you see years and years
later in a John Wick film
[Music]
series what you missed him from
there I did something to you didn't I
yeah Katie watched her entire family
burn to death that is beyond traumatic
we see this interesting turn with Katie
where she realizes both her and Winston
have their childhoods destroyed by this
man and it's not about going after the
player it's about going after the system
which is Cormac she realizes there is no
justice unless she creates Justice and
that's what she does at the
end we boiled this scene all the way
down to nothing just looks feeling
expression and Katie got her Vengeance
Winston
closure be
SE where does Winston end up at the end
of this
journey Winston has looked over his
shoulder his entire life and I think
when the job of killing Cormac is done
and the adjudicator shows up and says
okay give me the keys these premises are
under a temporary suspension until the
high table deems otherwise he realizes
wait a second this is going to be the
same issue I've just accomplished all of
this and now I'm going to be catering to
you again and be looking over my
shoulder again so it's a spur of the
moment
decision really what we learn in the
show is how Winston and his personality
as a hotel manager but also as a
gangster as a Crim Lord as a just a
great character how does he build this
hotel in His image when you meet him at
the very end he's beginning to take on
those characteristics of the Winston we
know in the John Wick film series so you
see him in It's the final image with the
exact wardrobe that Ian McShan had the
first time you saw him in John Wick one
the polka doed Ascot the Blazer the
exact martini and you're off to figure
out what's going to be the next 25 30
years before you see him again
[Music]